[Music]
this week it's time for a special allow
not gage here tonight to whisk you away
to the beautiful tropical trouble-free
white little-known fact
culturally and politically Hawaii's a
hellhole being one of the bluest most
regressive states in the Union with
full-time regressive activists promoting
ideas like a basic universal income of
1500 a month for doing nothing an $18
minimum wage or entirely doing away with
the Department of Homeland Security or
ice to enforce our own legal immigration
law if it sounded too outlandish to be
true it did to us too so we excited to
head on down to the local leftist
protests to see what they were about all
right so we're on our way to the j-20
planning meeting in Honolulu
whatever the hell that is I don't know
what it is but I do know that there's
again the push for a living wage and you
know professional protesters so I assume
it would be similar to the Grand Rapids
College social platform is testing Trump
the truth yes the Trump resistance the
inauguration of resistance yes and I
don't know what that means now unlike
the times we've gone undercover knock a
Jared and I went to this publicly
advertised open invitation meeting very
upfront about who we were we just wanted
to listen to be civil and you guess how
that turned out
hi my name is steven crowder cheered
right-wingers conservative but always
want to hear what you'd love to say just
visiting and seeing seeing what the
other half of the other country believes
and why and trying to learn from it so i
think we're in an era where people have
a hard time with disagreements and
staying civil painting the wrong
position as you know whatever it is it
could be racist it could be homophobic
it could be classist it's just whatever
the identity politics are of the day and
not a lot gets discussed so
see that you are doing this I do I have
a blog if that's okay if not you want
out of me
yeah okay so is there a reason why it
okay okay screeching ring okay sure yeah
fueling public spaces we have to but we
need a film okay so you can ask me
anything if you if you if you want any
questions my name is steven crowder have
a website called ladder with Crider calm
so I'm trying to be straight for as
possible libertarian raised in a
socialist province in Sabac saw the
ramifications firsthand can't stand it
don't want to see that happen to the
country I moved to but I'm always open
to see why Americans would disagree with
that yeah I am a I work with them
support a lot of same causes and we like
to talk to people and we should like to
engage with people from different views
to kind of understand and start an
actual dialogue which is something that
doesn't seem actually because you talked
a lot about starting Delaware long
should start a lot of dialogues lotta
was prouder doc yeah CRO WD er yeah I
know it's confusing what was six McLain
you guys being here and well I think we
don't want to come in in San negative
it's we're just we're always we go to
all these different functions for
example to show on Thursday we're
syndicated show we had a trans
transgender individual named Blair wife
come on a show to talk about the trans
military band disagree on some issues
actually greeted a lot of issues I teach
the way that it affects people in
military with current pensions I hate
the way was announced I hate that the
president seems more keen to be tweeting
and taking some some some action but
leave people on all the time we disagree
with the way I was just go out to any
function whether we are to
to see and explore ideas I'm not sure
how I feel about this we are actually
here to do work and to communicate or to
know the report back to one under the
work that we have been doing
I don't feel comfortable having this and
think someone observational no project
and I certainly don't want to think of
time debating j-20 is very clearly
antitrump and everything that that
agenda stands for we're not here as if
this is our meeting right now you're
just a base how am I here to be here I'm
here to listen forget the camera still
going it's on her leg look what's on
your shorts kind of middle we were at
record in Ohio we have to stop stop
recording here's my big moment is it
good job been constituted by gentlemen I
will other bloody right I know when I
add my bananas simple to show up our
permission
but we asked her permission I believe I
believe but we asked for permission and
the only problems when we said we were
conservative and I've been very
respectful but now I am videoing because
of this is kind of a problem no one ever
tax takes you're videotaping we're
talking about health care we don't need
to spend one trillion dollars per year
on the administrative overhead of
private health insurance and so that's
something I like to talk about
[Music]
would you about to talk about that well
I was about on your blog at another time
no no I'm not going to be the platform
the blog on another time you can't just
take a parting shot kind of cowered in
here to take up on what you just said
you want to talk about health care yeah
I'm not gonna hijack Jeremy do it okay
we don't know a whole lot about health
care and you want you want a lot about
it I know quite well I just buried I
just very two ants become socialized
healthcare so it's passionate to me
passion tissue leaving we got we got it
we understand it but when the dollars
expected that's the promise you can't
say who you are who you're with without
them kicking you out
not only where we kicked out of this
publicly advertised meeting for being
aggressive but they called the cops on
us
and posted warnings to all their friends
on social media regarding quote alright
trolls like myself my wife and this not
gay Jared t-shirt which by the way is
available at lotta with credit shop comm
along with our socialism's for fat good
shirt and of course mug Club to ensure
that these videos continue thank you for
the plug Hawaii j-20 turned out at a
local Jay 20 organizations we're staging
a protest at the Federal Building
demanding that we do away with the
Department of Homeland Security and ice
so we wanted to go on down and check it
out but this time we had to lay low
I am Ultimo gold worthy and this is my
esteemed colleague Oliver bone oh yeah
[Music]
it is a fine day to protest all
legislative official when it comes to
matters of national security and the
ones that are filming over the earth
they're all together hmm
are we not here to engage in civilized
protests
I made your partner what seems to be the
problem ma'am
oh hi Thank You Phil turns out
professional protesters don't know
anything about actual law Oh
your man appears to be under the wrath
you start feeding us Sara getting
insight into it what might I ask is the
problem good sir can you extrapolate you
know you guys doing all this screaming
and service in sp Robert okay it is not
a fine day for protest not a day did I
warn you before hundreds they were
protesting today and going into these
offices no this must be some new form of
dance one which they discuss is a hash
tag okay we come in every Tuesday every
Tuesday for the right and to the left
or neither of them gainfully employed
that's a bit much time away from my
travels and work what an enjoyable
procedure of expressing oneself to the
right even the public don't agitate them
either okay hold on a second if these
people are the agitators every Tuesday
they agitate it's their thing they have
a hashtag where's this trunk Tuesday
which loosely translates from Hawaiian
to English we're agitating pricks every
Tuesday so unlike the childish tantrum
throwing left we decided to wait our
turn and wait our turn and continue
waiting our turn
officer what have a word for a moment
because I do believe there are issues of
the utmost importance which could
require your attention let it inform you
the group of course much more elusive
legend supporting your policies and of
course hashtag backing room I Bible to
do research for the people who are
entering the office right now you'll see
that you're the case so we are here to
exercise our rights really in support of
those doing a tremendous job keeping us
safe well you're doing now you're
agitating and that's what you're doing
yes I can understand why they might feel
that where these are advertising people
try and make them out act out that fish
oh we wouldn't want make anyone I got
the typing of the utmost politeness try
anything with their protests you know go
ahead I want to allow to protest the
policies they protest like right now
you're kind of hot so you're gay
well it is very difficult to make an
appointment and have a discussion in a
civilized an hour with people who refuse
to go slow
that young man with a sweet boy just
gave a fantastic name he referred to us
as protesters protesting protesters
rather than I read into it so you want
us to wait for them to enter and enter
the later time okay or the other but the
first right they wanted to believe it is
ironic a minute for people who despise
our officers in blue to run to you the
moment they feel as though they are
uncomfortable we're not even good of
Ireland to say for themselves simply for
a camera being running I talked with a
stranger so long unfollow
they said he's that make sure when I
starting this blog when inside building
coming out absolutely not but what I
asked is about disrupting the flow for
them to Goulding professionally protest
every Tuesday it would seem as though
that could be slightly inconvenient
would you not agree oh he went to heaven
after football no I do believe in soul
here is the unfair treatment people who
seek to BCI's versus those who act like
children killing oh also not ask for
your present when they staged the
protesting died in late it is this
Saturday with a reenacted the act of
dying in a protest of modernized
care I shall engage in a reenactment of
my own I do believe it is time for me to
aspire to my sermons pine overcoat
if only I could have had other textfield
health care
here what do you my mother excited I
just heard the boys goes blues oh yeah
we go until one of the local leftists
came back to accuse us of being Bosnian
terrorists I wouldn't have believed it
either had I not actually experienced it
let's go to the tale of the tape
[Music]
are you thinking of us I do believe she
just accuse us of international
terrorism so what the crime is they're
not more agitated or cures of terrorism
she does she does she thought it was a
brief my second don't you friend
but that could actually encourage
violence against us do you think but
that's a crime sometimes we choose one
of international terrorism I know my
rights
piezoelectric shows me a parent of a
police officer yes you heard correctly
Bosnian terrorists but moving on as
though that's normal we learned
something here that we never expected to
learn turns out you don't need
identification to enter the Federal
Building at all if you're just
collecting welfare Social Security you
really need an escort
all the little questions is an ESCO
fused in lieu of identification our
people not required to present i need a
federal building that would be odd it's
not very secure it would seem at the
least inappropriate where they go but
when he of them entered without
identification at all what that mom had
no case yep that's all true so when it
was time for Archibald and Oliver to
enter the Federal Building they knew
what to do we request an escort unless
I'm mistaken I would very much
appreciate the law explained to me yes
please clarify others might be confusing
I do not require a valid ID to go to the
Social Security office to reap benefits
but I do to speak with my elected
official okay
then there's Social Security or what it
is we're gonna ask oh okay
this is if you guys know the XCore times
are at 9:30 and I want to cut oh that's
on your backpack so just naturally she
doesn't cuz there's no more escort
session so we return tomorrow morning
and 9:30 we can come and claim a Social
Security with all escort
what a fantastic country Thank You of us
up here newly coined by that gentleman
as protesters protesting protesters I am
audible Goldsworthy and this is my
esteemed colleague all of the wards me
today we learned that you may show up
without a fight but to protest your
locally elected officials for
departments like the homeland security
and ice which they demand must be done
away with at the taxpayers expense also
very conveniently we shall return in the
mall without identification requesting
an escort to reap the benefits of Social
Security this is modern America where
discourse is discouraged disagreement
this agreement is stifle the not allowed
but social security without any
identification is incorrect
[Music]
like this video subscribe by clicking
the subscribe button it's Atkinson Estes
Circle now it used to be a square which
most buttons aren't squares
let's that's on a phone they're square
buttons on phones with most buttons are
circles you understand what I'm talking
about or watch the recommended video
which is popping up in a box or
subscribe at lateral credit.com /mu club
join the mud clips you can get the daily
show and that means that you are not
beholden to the YouTube censoring
overlords let's be honest you like being
there where you are under their thumb
power bottom you